thank you
[Music]
hello hey what up Richard Lee and
welcome to Lobby game spots weekly
haggar every Tuesday 2PM Pacific right
here on gamespot.com do you hear that
Echoes live here that's the sound of
billions of galaxies worth of
exploration
inspiration oh yeah it is only one
Galaxy I thought it was no 18
quintillion planets
quintillion yeah but really is is that
worth sixty dollars we're gonna talk
about no man's Sky uh pretty soon here
on the lobby uh We've also got Mike
Mahari here right before he heads off to
Europe where I just was for two weeks so
uh I can get if you have any questions
about Europe now is the time I believe
you're flying in a couple of hours okay
now is the time to ask some questions
how many three questions how many
British nickels are in a dollar
there's no nickels no there are no
nickels that is that is a American thing
they may be made of nickel I don't know
but they're a dollars in other countries
they're yeah like idiot countries who
like got money after Europe oh [__] you
just call that like Eritrea you hear
that irritating yeah like South Sudan
maybe he's got Sudanese dollars I don't
know you're better yeah take that on our
Sudanese newest country in the world
get off
go to IGN I love you guys now we love
you you guys are cool
um second question
um how do I get to the Eiffel Tower
from London yeah you can take a train if
you want you can see what part of one is
then
okay third question oh I got three yeah
I saw the Eiffel Tower two weeks ago all
right for real what's cool what's like
your uh
favorite restaurant or Pub that I should
go to in London I was gonna say in all
of Europe in the world our favorite Pub
uh because I used to play football
soccer sorry uh for them as the star of
Bethel green on Bethel Green High Street
it's my favorite my buddy Rob owns it a
great place favorite restaurant
I love Nando's I miss Nando's Nando's is
great wagamamas as well these names are
perfect here's the thing where you like
order your pizza and like set that weird
Italian restaurant no that's the place
because you're going to Gamescom as well
right yep because there's one of those
there too what's that called again I
thought it was no no no Nando's is the
Portuguese piri prairie chicken place
okay so they only really saw chicken you
get a you know there's like a level of
heat you want yeah yeah you can get that
I always get the Malik some Irish um I
suck hot things uh and then wagamama's
thank God I'm gonna be I mean this is
gonna be really bad now because I think
I don't know if it's a green or a
Japanese place it might be something
else but they do like little bowls of
like noodles and stuff that's right I
remember that being Japanese cool
Japanese okay it might be it might have
a couple different influences forget the
name of the of the pizza place is it
like man here we go I was watching
something recently they said like
chicken tikka masala is the dish of
choice in the UK I'm not joking it
sounds like a joke it's Scottish
I'm not joking really it's actually
Scottish chicken tikka masala is when I
think it like this is not a joke I think
glasgow's or it was either Glasgow I
think it was guys it sounds like a
Glasgow sorry
um is that it was basically they added
milk because it was too hot so that's
why it's so popular in England because
it's like not really real Indian food
okay so yeah chicken tikka masala and
what's the other one uh there's another
one that was that's like everyone thinks
it's like a staple Indian food that is
actually not it's actually made in Great
Britain like Curry yeah another Curry I
forgot what it's called huh it's not
it's chicken taken oh whatever whatever
okay send it in your emails to we don't
have an email address tweet Mike
whatever your answer it is no not Pizza
Hut people think Pizza Hut
God damn it it's not Pizza Hut it's
called something else it's the worst sit
never go there we have to find out what
it is just to warn him off but to
basically the place where you go in it's
like who the f it's like somebody you
know when you play factorio and you
don't know how to set the thing up right
in the first time and it's super
inefficient that's what this restaurant
is you go in you order a pizza they give
you like a vibrating thing then you go
pick up your pizza and then you like pay
for the pizza
after you've gotten the pizza that's bad
they send you somewhere else that's in
Germany or London it's in both if you
have social anxiety it is the worst
scenario to walk into because you have
no idea what you should be doing but
everyone around you seems to understand
and you don't want to ask anyone because
you're in London and no one talks to
each other there's no one there to help
you uh I'm gonna keep looking on Google
Maps throughout the show so until I can
find this place so we can tell you not
to go there
um but yeah great to have you here I've
been away for two weeks you have I got
married you did yeah I got this ring now
weird means I can do that has the cards
thing where you like walks away one for
luck one to get ready for a fight yeah
exactly yeah which one are you getting
ready for Mark on your face
um so I was away for two weeks
what great video games come out in the
past two weeks oh God abzu
is good I didn't like absu no I really I
played about an hour of zoo and I was
like nah did you like Journey yeah I
think it's better than Journey really I
do so I like journey and I like what's
that like Minecraft underwater game
[Music]
not even close no it's called Minecraft
subnautica I like subnautica I like
diving games I I don't know why it just
didn't I mean it might be a mood thing
maybe Journey sapped all that out of you
it was very like Journey like I was
holding down the button to go except
it's not desolate and Barren that's good
no it's fine they're different okay I
still haven't found the name of this
place but Vapiano that's it right here
vapianos sounds like everything I love
papes
you think if they like pizza doesn't
work out they'll just like
rotate the business Vapiano Sleek chain
for self-service Italian Fair that's
what they say don't go to Vapiano if you
if you are a sad Sudanese owner of a
Vapiano I'm so sorry not the show for
you it's destroyed that demographic yeah
uh was there any other games that came
out it was slow right headlander oh yeah
I'll play a little bit of that seemed
okay it's good fun you didn't hate that
too no
we talk about no man's sky and that
doesn't seem all right
and I'm not like super familiar with the
castle Roy genre but it seemed like a
sort of a light version of that it's a
very dense compact version of that right
yeah it's a surprise episode of Kentucky
root zero come out too oh yeah now that
that's a huge episode four yeah but it
wasn't like a surprise drop they are
they all pretty much are when that comes
out it's just like hey who's new is that
it now or is there one there's one more
okay wow a few years ago right now yeah
2013. crazy stuff all right well that
was nice we talked about a couple of
video games because let's be honest
we're gonna be talking about one video
game for the most of today's show uh but
before we do that Michael mahardi hey
you're a person who enjoys civilizations
you are currently in one right now
you're flying to another one pretty soon
yeah and then to another one after that
yeah Germany Gamescom and then back to
another one place it doesn't have a
civilization
sets it on
I don't know
actually that's you know what let's not
get into that one particularly touchy
subject uh but uh civilization six you
play did you see a little koi look down
because I forgot which one it was yeah
um first number one in a while now rice
yes what five or something
yeah they went off and that they're
beyond Earth uh thingy uh there was an
expansion for that as well Rising tide
yeah late last year or was it early yes
uh it was October I think last year okay
so yeah Fair access I mean they put out
XCOM as well a couple of months back so
they're no strangers to uh to putting up
big games uh but civilization six first
one in a little while uh I guess the
sort of this is the fair access games it
is they're like sort of darling yeah I
mean it's the most basic question to ask
first of all what is new in this one
because it looks relatively familiar
um the only major difference I've seen
so far is around the cities yeah they're
doing what they call unstacking cities
so it's it's hard to talk about
civilization about something boring but
like aside for people that don't love it
so essentially the cities used to be on
one hextile on these Maps like these uh
chessboard Maps now instead of like
every time you build a new building
throughout your entire playthrough which
could last like eight hours the
universities the barracks won't all go
on one tile there would be these
different districts that go up so like
you're taking up more than one tile so
it's actually one of those things that
affects way more than you might think
Rob Handler and I both played about four
hours 150 turns right and it took us
four hours to do that because we were
learning so many new things in this new
game but you know step five on stacked
military units so you can't just have
this massive Army on this one tile of
death they called it right now the
cities you'll have to wait until you
build like a campus District so you can
build a university
um you know like an observatory the
science the actual buildings uh you know
same thing with encampments you'll build
an encampment then you can build like
the barracks and the actual like
training grounds for soldiers what this
does is not only makes you consider the
map more because you get adjacency
bonuses so if you build an aqueduct next
to a river but also next to a university
it's gonna get a bonus oh cool um so the
observatory like up high on a mountain
exactly so if you build a campus next to
a mountain range like you'll um you'll
get a bonus for the tier science output
um so so that kind of encouraging you to
put a City close to a bunch of other
stuff yeah so you want to group certain
things like encampments do really well
on their own though because this
actually affects the military strategy
of the game I'm not traditionally a
military player I like culture like for
people in familiar civilization
essentially you just like build up like
Hollywood you build up your
entertainment industry you build up uh
your great artists thinkers use these
people to pretty much influence other
civilizations to follow you like kind of
idolize you but military now instead of
just attacking one city tile and laying
Siege to that it's a little more
strategic because if you're near these
two mountain ranges you can put an
encampment right between them like
Thermopylae and kind of close off the
Gap yeah so not only do you have to
attack the city but you also have to
worry about troops coming out of the
encampment right um and then if you look
at a city and you know for a fact if
your spies are telling you that like
Marseille is a science inclined City and
it's giving uh the French Catherine de
Medici in this game she's not French
it's a cool story behind her but yeah
Italian yeah but she like married into
the French royal family in the late
Lorenzo's sister
maybe everyone knows Lorenzo Lorenzo's I
know a guy named Lorenzo that works at
uh vapianos yeah
um likes to blow those sweet coils yeah
is that does that work I don't know uh
so I talk about no man's Sky yeah they
can't tell
so you'll you'll attack a city and
you'll know that's a huge scientific
City and there they have a lot of
advanced technology so you're like all
right I'm going for Marseille because I
can see they have a really flourishing
uh campus District as well as a few
wonders which are their own tile as well
oh so you can take the city and take all
that stuff as well you can you can
attack certain districts at a time
before you even get to the Palace okay
so that's where it becomes strategic if
you want to just halt their scientific
production without actually eliminating
them and using the military force you
could just take their campus District
defend it hold it that's cool and
that'll like boost you in science um
same thing with like uh I don't know
like aqueducts if it's a huge City
that's population it's like booming you
used to go for the aqueducts yeah if
it's a naval City you can I think
there's a dockyard district I don't know
there's a bunch we didn't try but it
makes you consider the map a lot more
down the road because each city is a
little more specialized and one of the
main tenets with tenants with
civilization six that for Access is
going for is making each playthrough
different which sounds like a marketing
thing but this thing is with civ5 you
could essentially follow the same
pattern if you wanted to toward Victory
every time yes this um there's another
thing they're doing with this not just
the unstacking cities but Act of
research which essentially functions
like this list of side quests which
there already were in civ5 but now
you know you'll be researching a new
technology and it'll tell you right
under it what you could do to boost that
so you have to wait like five or ten
less turns which is huge uh if you're
like researching construction if you
happen to build a quarry in that time
it'll just give you the technology so
what I found in those four hours three
or four hours we were playing every turn
there was much more to consider but
there's also less waiting uh this time
around a lot of problems that every
civilization game has structurally is
that the first like 100 turns are really
fun you're figuring out where you want
to go with your civilization the last
hundred turns or that Victory Rush when
everybody's going for cultural uh
economic scientific victories but those
middle turns can kind of get boring
because you're having like you might be
like in this battle up North but also
waiting those 12 turns for like uh you
know space exploration
um now there's just with that active
research side quest tab you can keep
boosting things that will also make you
maybe Branch out of your comfort zone uh
unstacking cities is more to consider
when you're attacking defending cities
and just when you're building them in
general so the fact that they're
designing around the pillar of making
each playthrough different actually rang
true for the few hours we played it was
Rob's first civilization I think he
found the same thing he was learning not
just six his new rules but the
civilization Foundation yeah totally I
mean even when you're talking about
these games like this is these are the
conversations we have yeah it's it's
like there's two ways to have this
conversation there's one with people who
know about Civ yeah which is like the
super you know there's like a bunch of
people in the chat probably being like
what is any of this mean yeah yeah um so
I guess for newcomers do you think it's
in any way less you know I feel like
x-com was one of those great games that
like broke people into a genre they may
not have otherwise touched you know the
the reboot of that game was perfect for
fans like me who love the old games but
also like you know we're accessible
enough as well is that even like can you
do that with service or anything about
this game that's like more accessible I
mean how it looks already I think is
probably a bit more using the eye yeah
it's like a combination of Civilization
Revolution the console versus art style
with civ5 but they wanted more character
to it because yeah um I think it was Ed
Beach the lead designer so actually one
more like behind the scenes thing is
really exciting with this is that the
two expansions for civ5 Brave New World
and gods and Kings were like widely
lauded and like they're said to have
made civ5 the game it should have been
at launch the teams that made those
expansions
combined and they're making six right
and then the the Creator that's him he's
leading this up Sid Meier's not attached
to this he's just like a supervisor like
as usual lately um but they are just
stands behind him whipping yeah exactly
yeah just like pretending an idea was
his no I'm kidding he seems like a great
he's a very nice person he's a very nice
guy yeah um he is they're essentially I
it's cool because they're making a new
game the foundation not editing an
existing game now so it's cool to see
what they're doing but yeah they're one
of their things is every civilization is
potentially a new the first civilization
for somebody like Rob Handler in this
case
um and there there are tutorials in
place but they're also
kind of the fact that it's different
like each turn there's a lot more to
consider they said the learning curve is
actually a little easier because you're
not doing these things in the first
hundred turns and being like I have no
idea what I just did and then having
these boring middle turns and then
coming the victory Rush you're like what
the hell is happening it's kind of like
easing you into it so yeah you'll
probably have to play like 10 hours
before you start really getting the loop
but that's like one of the rewarding
things about the game it's still
entertaining because you know you have
Espionage you have diplomacy
to not go too deep into diplomacy is
really good now because they've always
tried to make these other leaders
characters themselves that you can
actually interact with and like
manipulate and figure it out but now
they have historical agendas so like
Teddy Roosevelt will always do the speak
softly carry a big stick like he'll pull
you if you're in too close with borders
but he will fight you but they also have
hidden agendas that you have to figure
out yourself through spies or just what
they're doing so if you know like
um
kin Chi Huang I think with a Chinese
leader is um like building a lot of
settlers you'd be like okay he's trying
to expand now I got to take up the real
estate while I have time right so it's
really there's a lot of things feeding
into this that seem minor at first but
actually have these Ripple effects that
kind of affect the overall like
turn to turn and like play through to
play through Rhythm of the game it's
cool stuff yeah civilization six Peter
Brown hi when did the first civilization
come in
civilization came out
teen 91. okay that's yeah
nice work yeah I was gonna say it's 25th
year anniversary this year oh really
yeah okay I didn't know that nice work
that's impressive thank you that's my
25th year anniversary this year it's
about to say how old
is all the civilization
that was that was the setup but you just
did it for me when when were you born in
1991 September 22nd first day same month
same birthday as Bilbo and Frodo Baggins
I'm not kidding not kidding I'm not fake
people you go to Europe they're [__]
not real I'll go to Europe that's not
impressive I'll go to Europe my two
friends were born the same day as Hitler
what day is that well not the same day
the same year same day be weird I didn't
go to school with two like 80 year old
Germans your friends were born the same
yeah
uh same uh same but I had the same
birthday
same birthday as Randall Cunningham go
Eagles
uh what I think yeah save is just
slightly older than you September 1991
probably I'm guessing not the start of
September like I was I kicked off The
Fall release schedule
first game out Mike mahardi
I feel like March is the fall of baby is
being born
that's like when all my friends were
born in March March my family too a
bunch of songs summer eleven yeah yeah
that was a New Year's baby oh never mind
I hope my mom's not watching this we
could just ask her yeah
I I was a happy accident same me too
yeah siblings are well six yeah six
years after my brother I I asked if I
was an accident and their responses know
you're a bonus oh now my dad literally
used the phrase happy accident so at
least he said that goes no you were a
mistake civilization six
out
soon October 21st same day as
Battlefield one same day as Battlefield
1 and Hitler's birthday there you go
folks
definitely not I don't think is it close
let's check it out we can cut that
segment off of like already if there's
oh no April 20th okay I got excited
because I saw 20. but actually it was
about six months away as far as you can
possibly go okay uh hi hi
let's talk about the game on everyone's
lips
on everyone's Minds on everyone's
PlayStation 4 looking at PSN and
hopefully on everyone's PC come Friday
the No Man's Sky yeah it's mine actually
it's your Sky it's mine oh really yeah
you got up there first yeah it was me
you were there pre-patch that was me
joining the space we'll talk about the
pre-patch stuff later uh but first of
all I just wanted to I there's a bunch
of ways you can talk about this game yes
first I just want to kind of ask are you
enjoying it like that's I think the most
important thing so Peter are you
enjoying no man's Sky I am enjoying no
man's Sky I've played about 20 hours now
combined uh pre-patch and post patch
um it is a a very interesting game that
is that is very big and so big that it's
really hard to even understand it um
so I love the way it plays with scale I
love the way it encourages you to seek
out new discoveries and it tempts you to
gain New Wealth so you can like get all
the you know the hot new rides and hot
new equipment
um yeah I mean I'm very much enraptured
in the experience right now and I am not
headed towards the center of the Galaxy
right yeah either am I oddly enough but
for different reasons probably so that's
the thing I one of the things that has
been like the sort of the the curse and
the blessing of this game is that how
vague they've been about it and I think
in one way it's set expectations in a
weird way for some people where they
think that maybe this is a different
type of games what it is but in another
way it's like so much about this game
like when I when you start the game off
I was like my ship's broken I'm supposed
to find Hydra blah blah and blah blah
and I'm like I have no idea what any of
this stuff is yeah and like that whole
experience has been fascinating in the
same way that like playing Minecraft for
the first time we're playing Terraria
for the first time uh you've played for
like 20 hours now does that continue
that sort of sense of discovery
sense of Discovery yes but you
definitely come to to grips with what
you should be doing or what you could be
doing at this stage I am not
there aren't that many surprises in
terms of the bigger picture maybe I'll
find an element I hadn't seen before
right or an item I hadn't seen but the
the bigger picture stuff like what it
means to travel from one solar system to
another what it means to discover a
planet you know when you find an outpost
on that planet or an anomaly in space
like what that means and what you can
gain from it I've kind of seen all of
that but all that stuff remains
interesting because each one is like an
egg and inside the shell like a bunch of
different elements right that are
different than they were the last egg
you cracked yeah it's crazy I was
watching Rob and Mary do their live
stream last night and they were bouncing
from planet to planet not finding any
life whatsoever while at the same time I
was playing in a solar system where like
those four planets and they all had
teeming with life like it was too much I
was like making so much money yeah and
Mike you've played a bit since it's
launched uh how were you finding no
man's sky so far yeah I only I didn't I
only played about three hours I think
um and I knew it was gonna be a survival
game I really like survival games but I
think with this I wasn't I wasn't going
into it expecting more just like
exploration and uh so right now I've
just been figuring out you know like the
inventory and the actual survival Loop
of collecting like Isotopes for your
weapon or for your uh
certain like boosters uh you know
collecting like actually crafting and
whatnot but so far it's intriguing I
mean the my favorite part is like
actually coming up off a planet with no
loading screen just like pointing up at
the sky and just boosting as fast as you
can going to another planet doing the
hype like the the speed boost the pulse
boost I think it's called and then going
down into another planet and landing and
it's all seamless that's like incredible
that part is really gratifying for me
the survival I feel maybe like I said uh
the farther I get in maybe I'll actually
like start to enjoy the survival more
and kind of accept that alongside the
exploration I've been hearing that the
farther in you get the more you'll get
acclimated to the survival elements
you'll get better equipment yeah I think
I'm assuming you figure you start to
figure out the stuff you kind of need to
be connecting all the time yeah yeah and
you come to terms with like the the
process like the order of operations
right like before you sell anything
before you go hunting for anything make
sure all your equipment is filled with
with energy yeah that includes your ship
like that includes you know your the
hazard production too like everything
like take care of them that first and
you're pretty much good to go and have
fun but yeah the early goings you can
definitely find yourself in a pinch
where you're like crap why did I sell
that material I need it for XYZ or I
kept landing and then because like your
launch thrusters require certain
elements to launch so you can't take off
the planet without it at the start I was
like terrified to land my [__] because
if I didn't land it near it was a
plutonium or whatever it's called I like
I couldn't take off again now I have
like a cargo full of the [__] just to
make sure because it was like so scary
to me yeah but yeah it's like that kind
of uh I guess yeah you kind of you
you've you start to get us like a sixth
sense for the stuff the the plates you
need to kind of keep spinning yeah like
unless I'm finding Sentinels which get
at this point where I'm at where I'm
finding really rare materials centers or
Sentinels are guarding them right it
feels more like a survival game now
because I'm incur incurring damage
that's really tangible and hard to fix
but I guess I'm at odds with the idea
that this is mostly a survival game
because I've been on the worst planets
you know that you know just really bad
ones and
it doesn't feel that threatening like
yes the winds are blowing and yes
there's a lot of radiation but like my
suit can handle it you can always just
get in your ship and just drive up fly
up you can always just do that I mean
that's one of the crazy things is like
an outpost on the other side of the
planet that takes longer to get to than
another planet right yeah like it's
crazy the way scale works so yes space
is sort of like a sanctuary in a way
where you can get out and take care of
yourself but you do start getting
attacked more sudden it'll start chasing
you into space right and those Pursuits
are the ones I'm finding now oh I really
feel like challenged
sandals chase you into space so if you
engage this one instance that I can
refer to I don't know how it applies
everyone else's experience but I was
fighting Sentinels on the ground it was
like two drones and like a quadruped
Sentinel I took off in my ship or they
were still looking for me whether or not
they were looking for me was the reason
this happened Sentinel ships then
started warping into okay and I killed
it I killed the ones there and they're
like well there's more Ships coming so I
had to find a different planet they
didn't pursue me down to there there
wasn't I so I don't think it's this
Pursuit that lasts from ground to space
but I think that was a particularly
volatile solar system uh so I guess the
you know I feel like the the amount of
conversations were in hype and
expectations and stuff around this game
in particular have have been crazy over
the past couple of months uh but now
they're on the other side of the launch
at this is a game that was like Sony
were pushing it very very hard obviously
you know hello games very small team but
they were sitting on the main stage of
you know since the game awards and it
was E3 and then it was the next D3
um there was a lot of hype and
expectations around around this game
youth hasn't met your expectations of
what you thought this game was it has
completely
um and my expectations were that this
would be a world that is bigger than I
can really get a grip on
um that I can seamlessly transition from
planet to outer space to a new solar
system that I will be making discoveries
and that there is a tangible hope that
one day what I do will be noticed by
somebody else or I may encounter
something that is a product of someone
else's efforts but again not that
there's a guarantee just that there's a
hope that that will happen and all those
things have been fulfilled and for me
the thing that that's even uh more
gratifying is to discover this sort of
like mysterious storyline that that's
kind of happening that it's not told to
you really you kind of You See It
Through The Eyes of your character as
they Ponder what's happening around them
because there's no common language you
know right everything you kind of just
have to suppose everything based on what
you see that has been the nice surprise
on top of the expectations that were
fulfilled right so I feel totally
gratified I the the story stuff I'm
surprised how much I really like it I I
can't really in video games at least I
can't really think of another game
that's that's done it this way where
it's this it's it's so vague and so
alien like everything about this feels
it's almost like I was trying to sort of
explain it this morning
um to my wife it's almost it's almost
like you're reading an encyclopedia
about a Sci-Fi world like where it's
like it's the information that they're
telling you is is you don't even know
one piece of it and it's part of a much
grander thing and you can never it's
like the opposite of most video games
where they're like this is the word you
live in yeah these are the rules this
one it seems like you could probably
play the entire game and I still have no
idea what the goddamn has going on it's
so hard to come to come to grips with it
and you know like you're by yourself for
the most part and like yeah you'll see
Trader ships in space stations but you
don't really see the Traders like unless
you talk to them but even though they're
not present but then you find someone on
a planet and you're like oh thank God
like another life form another like
human being who's trying to survive in
this world Not a Human Being another
life form that's trying to survive and
you get there and you have this moment
of Hope until you go talk to them and
you're like
they don't know what I'm I don't know
what they're saying yeah like we can't
communicate like I'm I feel more lonely
than ever because I can't relate to this
one thing that I found in so much time
like it's crazy how big it is
um but one thing I've kind of noticed
I'm following the atlas path right me
too I think and there's a lot of sort of
like religious allegory in there where
it seems to be
asking the big questions that a lot of
us maybe ask when we think about the
meaning of religion whether we're a part
of it or not um and I've been on both
sides of that conversation having forced
to been growing up a Catholic and a lot
of the questions I had when I was in
church that led to my me being sort of
an atheist as an adult I'm seeing those
same questions being asked around me in
this game
um not with any one perspective behind
it but just the questions are being
asked that's fascinating so uh yeah I
think it's uh it's it's much my
expectations but I also feel like my
expectations were like I've had a lot of
access to this game over the past couple
of years and I feel like for minority I
I kind of knew I had a decent idea of
what it was that it it wasn't but I
think there are some people who think
this is some sort of like massive you
know combat focused Space Opera and it
certainly is different about that yeah I
never got that I think my initial
impression when they first like showed
it at the Sony stage was it's like Elder
Scrolls in space right which is what
like it's very different because like
Skyrim when you're as dense as that no
like in terms of like quests right like
there's one Quest right there's just
like
as of now yeah like Skyrim Skyrim's this
finite thing so I took my time scouring
every inch whereas now it was so
overwhelming at first which you can
imagine there's like what 18 and a half
quintillion planets I think when the
math works out but
like the fact that it's it might as well
be infinite for all for us we're never
going to see everything so that was
overwhelming at first I was kind of like
what's the point of this I'm never gonna
find everything but then that became
like the driving force be like this is
curiosity incarnate like I'm just gonna
keep finding new things no matter how
long I play this game if I play this
game 25 years from now I'm gonna see new
things but I still am at that point
where I'm wondering the survival stuff
is actually like helping because I think
my initial concern before the game
released was like how much substance is
there on a planet to planet galaxy
galaxy basis but it's leading me to
believe that getting there will have
this nice like satisfying survival Loop
uh crafting Loop and also just the
traveling itself is so satisfying so I'm
looking forward to another
30 hours or so I think it is like from
and I haven't played nearly as much as
you Peter but from what I've had I think
it has like just enough substance like
I'd say that's the case there's a lot of
repetition in like outside buildings
yeah and it's I I was I was playing it
last night thinking like I don't know
why I'm not bored of this because like a
lot of it is quite like the same thing
over and over again and you're just like
saving up money to get the new thing and
then but like I wasn't born the planets
were like I was just like God this is
beautiful or like I keep getting
distracted and I'm getting distracted by
Mission or not missions but just like I
I guess activities that on the face of
it aren't like that amazing like okay
for instance for the past three hours
I've been trying to catalog every animal
on this one [__] class which I can't
understand why you would want to do that
because like the payoff is like a 300
000 right yeah like I can make that much
money just Mining and when I started it
I I didn't realize that and I've
actually accumulated about that much
just by popping down to the planet over
back but I have one animal left and I've
spent the past hour looking for this
bastarding thing here's a real ugly son
you can't see him from the sky can you
no I've literally like gone up flown to
the other side of Planet gone down and
like because they're day night cycles so
there's some animals only appear on one
side of the planet there's different
biomes on the planet so like there's one
place where there's loads of these
different planets have different
rotations right so the light cycle is
going to be long for some so like I'm
going all over the place and I've
literally like gone up and landed about
15 times looking for this one and it's
like I'm just scanning it's like nope I
know and now I know all the other
animals my heart their names so that's
going to be fun to like go to a new
planet and be like oh who are all these
strange animals I don't know because I
feel like I'm familiar with all these
other ones now but like that sounds so
boring that sounds like the most boring
thing in the world I'm just like playing
one of those stupid safari games that
come out on like the Wii and nobody buys
but it's like it's I've been doing it
and enjoying it yeah yeah interesting I
mean it's nice that the few times where
I have found myself bored I've taken a
step back and thought okay I could take
a break or I can look at these
opportunities in a different way right
right I could focus on mining I could
focus on travel I could focus on combat
if I want all right let's talk about
that stuff next okay okay no man's Sky
it's a video game where you can explore
you can wander you can shoot
animals and spaceships and all that sort
of stuff you can be a be a catalog or of
animals uh there's loads of different
ways to to play this game so well we
have the three of us here I wanted to
talk about some of the ways we've been
playing it at the moment uh Peter first
of all you've played more than any of us
combat wise how much like combat have
you done because I've barely scratched
it because I'm kind of terrified uh at
the beginning I tended to avoid avoid
Sentinels because the shooting kind of
sucks in this game like yeah it's really
not good
um but now I'm at the point where I'd
see a sentinel it's just a pain in my
ass I just want to get rid of it so uh I
think I've killed like 50 or just over
50 miles at this point but that's only
with a concerted effort to do so over
the past like four hours today
um there is some sorry have you done it
has your gun gotten better or something
like how have you sort of managed to
achieve it you know what my gun has
improved but I'm not noticing that big
of a difference in its performance apart
from being able to because you can use
your mining beam to kill enemies as well
in fact my mining beam is just as strong
strong as the blast attachment
um and it doesn't I don't have to reload
it right so there are cool down timers
that change noticeably apart from that
the strength of it outside of mining I'm
not really seeing a big difference right
um the space combat stuff is okay it's
very basic like hey here's the reticle
you're shooting based on the ship's
flight path trajectory and shoot in that
little circle and you're going to take
them down eventually I've only died in
combat once which was against uh a swarm
of Sentinels including the quadrupedal
ones right
um it was like the one time I came here
to watch him play today oh really yeah
it was the only time I died
um
so far
um yeah I don't know combat is there but
it's certainly not like any draw for me
yeah me neither I was I was I'm kind of
fascinated to see what had the PC one
handles I feel like the field of vision
doesn't feel particularly comfortable to
me at least on the planet if it kind of
works in space but maybe on the planets
it feels a little bit weird
um but I'm wondering what Max and
keyboards whether or not that'll make it
more fun right it'll make it more
accurate I'm sure but I'm not sure if
it'll make it more fun I don't think
it's gonna be fun because there's not
great variety of challenge yeah right
it's like most of the time it's those
drones it shoots Sentinels or it's like
murder animals yeah and like the animals
actually catch me off guard more in the
Sentinels like I find myself getting
berated by animals that I just can't
seem to kill where a sentinel will kind
of hover in place right these animals
are just erratically running around like
chomping at my heels so
uh yeah let's talk about some of those
animals then some of the weird ones
you're seeing because exploration and
like uh you know scanning these animals
to fill up your logs first of all every
time you scan like every time you go to
a planet or a solar system or you scan
an animal or a plant you can then sell
that information you like upload it to
the global sort of database and then
from that you get actually a decent
amount of money at the start it's not
bad yeah considering you can land on a
planet and scan maybe a dozen things in
your immediate vicinity and make a you
know cool 15 grand yeah it's pretty cool
um how what has been like some of the
Weird Animals you've come across so far
they're all weird they're all like a mix
of amphibian and mammal or
inexplicable like biology like one just
had kind of like a it looked like a like
a pyramid Like a Rock pyramid for a head
Pyramid Head yeah whoa I uh was he was
this was it dragging a massive like yeah
a sword knife behind it a lot of fog
someone wearing a plastic bag for a
helmet
um I can look I can recognize and
appreciate the variety that is out there
and that I can never predict what
animals are going to be but they are the
least interesting thing to me about this
guy oh yeah they're it's it's so clear
how randomized they are and they offer
me nothing of import other than lazy
money making opportunities where I don't
have to work very hard for it the the
concept of
being you know enamored with how strange
these things are is lost to me after the
200th weird-looking animals did you like
Spore
of the animals in this game yeah I don't
know why it's like I wish I could like
rotate the models and stuff and like
peek them apart I love naming them
stupid things like I call like five
different animals like T-Rex dog at this
stage because they've all got T-Rex I
haven't gotten into naming yet because I
don't feel like like I know someday
someone might say that's the reason
right I'll probably be dead
that would be like knobby knobby boy
they'll speed up the world somehow and
then we'll see it well that's what the
thing is with these crazy animals it's
almost like it's desensitizing me right
away that's what I'm gonna see down the
road like if I was born in real life and
the first two people I saw were like
Hulk Hogan and Richard Simmons
really interest me or creep me out that
much so I would just go through life and
I don't know if I I think I see these
animals and I'm like all right that's
probably the weirdest one I'm gonna see
and then you see one which is like
comparatively weirder but still
how much if you like crank it up to 10
right away where do you go from there I
wonder because like I saw some like all
the screenshots are going up now right
so like it's a destiny guy over at IGN
had like basically looked like sort of
like a Kaka demon where it was like this
floating octopus like yeah that was
pretty messed up I saw what looked like
a watermelon that was just bouncing
around yeah I've seen those too you know
what's what's really interesting to me
is that now that I'm seeing everything
else that people are sharing and stuff
they've seen right I'm noticing a lot of
parallels oh okay oh I've seen that
animal except it was yellow not green or
I've seen that line of dialogue from
that person in The Outpost right like
somebody was posting about you meet this
traveler from the Viking race and he's
talking about having a photo of like a
potential mate oh it's not really sultry
yeah I saw that okay like they're
actually there's variety here but
there's also like a lot of similarities
happening as well I guess they give it's
like implied variety because of the
scale of the world right you're like God
anything would be the case but then yeah
maybe when when you actually play the
game I'd be interested to play the
second time and see how much of that
yeah comes in as well uh what else can
you do in this game you can scan things
you can I guess mining like are you
enjoying the mining aspect of us it's
it's the fundamental part of the game
the you need to do a certain amount but
you can obviously do way way way more if
you just want to be like a Trader it's
like gambling right I mean you spend
enough time on a planet hoping to find
something of value and then when you do
you find like a massive cash of it
you're just like oh I'm the man like
you're just dreaming of all the money
you're gonna make you're then dreaming
what you're gonna buy with that money
and so at that point
the materials and the deposits become
the thing you're going to buy like
you're just it's the means to an end and
it's great to find it but when you're on
a planet that is like super desolate and
there aren't many resources I just
I cannot wait to get the hell out of
there I'm there for like five minutes
like nope nope huge waste of time I'm so
done get me off this planet I don't want
to play this game right now take me
somewhere interesting yeah I'm that's
why I'm scared to leave the planet I'm
on at the moment because there are just
massive like Columns of Gold Everywhere
uh and I'm in a space because like I
love going to the space station and then
seeing what the Traders around you are
trying to buy but they'll pay double for
right and then the fascinating thing
which I learned from Rob's video as well
uh they put up yesterday the five things
you can learn from other trade routes
things that you wish you knew yeah trade
route so if you watch the I guess the
the line like where they're flying yeah
you can kind of see yeah
multiple of these like space line you
know lines yes Chemtrails converge on to
one planet you might find a lot of stuff
there and and it's very true like there
was one planet I went to where I noticed
that it did have a lot of those and that
was one where I found the gravitinos I
think they're called uh that were worth
like 50k a pop right and they were just
all over the place but anytime I picked
one up like half a dozen sandals would
come chase after me so it was like
I'd like take a deep breath get out of
my ship scan the area and just Sprint
Sprint always keeping an eye on where my
ship was making sure I could get back
um yeah you're tough to leave that sort
of thing right when you have those
riches in front of you and then you're
making you're making all this money and
you're like well when is enough enough
like how much cash do I really want on
hand or how much time do I want to spend
making that money yeah if anybody asks a
question do you really need to dedicate
yourself to a profession uh you mind
sell data fly fight and trades do you
need to sort of min max or no those
aren't really the game isn't like that
at all there's no trade there's no
classes all these things you do are in
service of a bigger goal which is to
travel
yeah the only thing I can think of is at
least at the start with your because
you've got your multi-tool and your new
starship and then your your suit I guess
is that like the multi-tool you can sort
of like put upgrades in it which favor
maybe combash or favor mining but like
yeah you're doing both all the time
anyway right yeah it's not that
difference uh Mike what about you one of
your first three or four hours in the No
Man's Sky I've been what have you been
focusing on I think once I found a space
station where I could sell things I was
mining just to see how much money I
could get I forget what I'm sitting at
now I think I have at least uh 150 unit
150k units or something
um I was hoping that I could be like a
pirate pre-release which I don't know if
you can per se shoot down ships in the
air and collect materials off of them
but it's generally the same things
you're collecting it's usually Titanium
because that was my dream like
to go pirate someone and destroy their
ship take their resources get ready to
pulse jump with the guitar solo from
like Freebird playing middle finger in
the air and get out of there you just
want to be Cowboy beboppers yeah
essentially but yeah
that's what I've been trying to explore
as much as possible but the the light
survival elements have kind of taken
over and right now I think I'm still
is such a shallow part of the game that
I haven't really mastered the inventory
like management figured out what what
are you what elements are used for what
so far um I wanted I wanted I'm just
upgrading my ship and my exosuit as well
as often as I can I think that's my main
goal in the short term because I've
gotten to a third solar system I believe
I did the second like tier of the actual
Atlas quest to upgrade your hyperdrive
or whatever it is warp drive
um so yeah I kind of like splitting it
between economy The Mining and actual
just upgrades to myself and my ship
which is rewarding let me tell you right
now stop upgrading your ship
[Music]
[Laughter]
because you cannot add slots to your
ship oh yeah the only way to get more
slots is to buy a new ship which you can
then fit more augmentations and that's
the same way but can't you swap out
current like lasers on your ship though
for new ones
you can swap it out yeah but you better
be saving it for the next ship Why
didn't it's better off that way but when
you buy a new ship they come with
augmentations on already okay so
sometimes those are already better than
yours okay
um and then you're not scrapping things
or wasting resources to only sell it for
half and same with the multitude as well
eventually you're just gonna get like
you don't have enough money to buy a
better one yeah well I have the I
haven't used them I felt cheap using
them but I have the pre-order ship and
oh yeah
everyone's got these nice pre-order
ships that look like the ship that you
saw like on the cover just with a
different colors yeah and I am like I
want that X-Wing thing they had no
screenshots it's on the cover that's
what I'm thinking of this is the nose of
an X-Wing no I don't think so that's
what Randy has that's what I've seen a
couple of pre-orders maybe it is maybe I
just didn't look at it closely enough
yeah his one's got Sean Murray's face
all over as long as it's not a B wing me
and Josh Shaw it's not Star Wars I know
it's not Star Wars we used to we used to
argue about how stupid b wings are I
hope he's watching yeah honestly makes a
good point here uh which basically kind
of sums up how if I feel about this game
isn't that just Elite dangerous I mean I
really liked playing dangerous but Elite
dangerous was like too much for me like
I'm not that person I can't you have to
dedicate yourself it's like Eve I feel
you dedicate yourself to that one game
to me this is exactly the type of game I
wanted this is a very except accessible
game yes it's like a denser or like a
more compact version of of that right
where it's not like you're traveling
it's not so it's elite dangerous is
Broad and has no rules this one is quite
guided at the start and I guess it
continues to be guided depending on what
you want to do
um yeah and I'm really liking it uh
when's a review gonna be up Peter Brown
too I don't know it's tough because the
question is do you go to the center of
the Galaxy yes but there's another
question do you follow Atlas this sort
of mysterious Force that's pulling you
in a different direction
um then there are other things there are
other things I thought Atlas was pulling
you toward the center no no
these are the sort of things that when
I'm talking to people it's like you have
to ret you have to re-explain it to
everyone because this game is so
it's accessible but it's not
straightforward yeah the whole thing
with Atlas is counter-intuitive to the
center of the Galaxy like I've at this
point maybe four or five Atlas
interferences into the atlas Trail where
you kind of appear at these like temples
um
your character begins to question
okay I'm not headed towards anything am
I just going in circles I don't know do
I want to keep searching and figure out
the answer yes or no and so if you
choose yes it's like all right I'll keep
going but you're not getting any closer
to the center of the Galaxy like with
Alice I in fact in my experience doing
it I'm I'm literally going yeah I was
like dude
right sure so if you go to the center of
the Galaxy you're actually there's not
much of a story there I did that when I
was playing uh before the patch and I
actually got kind of disillusioned in in
terms of my Pursuit because it was so
much about how I made it not what not
about what was presented to me right at
that stage so I'm enjoying the atlas
path more but it's there's no certain
end so in terms of when the review is
coming I'd love to say by the end of
this week it might bleed into next week
all right but we have review a review
and progress up and you're going to be
continuing to sort of update that thread
yeah every day I'm gonna put up a
gallery with some of the coolest things
I saw and uh just moments that made me
think one thing or another and I'll be
sharing those uh every evening cool
awesome so check back on gamespot.com
real soon for all that hot stuff
all right I don't want it to be the
focus but what's going on here
exchanging fluids is that coffee
I hope so
looks like Diet Coke
neither uh I'm not done talking about no
man's Sky okay well actually I might be
done
so last week the I guess there was a you
know early version of the game sent out
to price there was a leak there was all
this there was no copies okay we paid
over a hundred dollars to have a copy
overnighted to us from New York oh
really wonderful yeah uh so you played a
bunch of the game pre this I guess 1.03
patch which came out on Monday there was
a big uh read me that Sean Mori wrote
about it uh adding quite a lot of
content to it uh so I guess I want to
ask you about the sort of main
differences between the game that we all
saw on launch and that experience
because it's sort of like a weirdly
fascinating insight into day one patches
and how much you can fundamentally
change a game right uh mere hours before
it came out so what were some of the big
differences that you experienced between
those two versions so the two big ones
for me I'll start with the first which
is uh your inventory and how much a
single unit can hold in terms of
resources right yeah so one slot in your
inventory can hold before the patch it
was 100 units of a specific material and
that was the same for your ship as it
was for your exos2 now your ship can
hold 500 per unit and your xs2 can hold
250 per unit that's only that's insane
yeah like my inventory is constantly
full I couldn't and that's not five
times more uh that's that's not right so
that makes the process of mining a much
more gratifying thing because you know
I'm not just getting a little bit of
wealth I'm getting wealthy like I am
collecting a lot of stuff and I'm going
back with my coffers full to trade in
that seems like a crazy balance of
change yeah it hasn't really impacted
the like the bigger picture uh actions
that I'm taking in terms of jumping
solar systems and stuff like that it's
mostly the moment to moment so I don't
think I don't think of it as dramatic I
just think of it as nice to have uh
that's nuts I saw a lot of quality of
life sort of stuff Rob was telling us
about yeah about like for instance in
the menus you couldn't just hit back you
couldn't just hit Circle you'd have to
yeah for every action you choose in a
menu you have to hold down the x button
with a cursor over a menu option to exit
out you used to have to do that as well
now you can just hit Circle that's nuts
but it got even worse like when you were
comparing you know if you were talking
to a Trader and you're like maybe I want
to buy your ship
now when you look at their ship it tells
you the price and then there's an option
to compare what uh items each ship has
before it didn't show you the price so
you automatically had to go to that
second menu and then to get out of that
you you had to do that holding down the
cursor again so it's a lot more
efficient in that sense uh in that in
Shaw's Sean's um readme or is his DOT
plan I guess
um he also talked about how the three
paths or three unique paths to play
through the game and they sort of like
served these up in a more
um I guess literal sort of sense did you
was the start of the game much different
or the the way the the start of the game
was pretty similar um the game basically
guides you into uh accessing your you
know a hyperdrive which lets you jump
from solar system to solar system
um and then it kind of frees you up to
do what you want you make a a decision
the moment you start the game which is
you sort of see this uh distressed
Beacon and it's it belongs to Atlas or
the atlas movement and you decide to
um activate it and somehow become in
tune with it
That Remains the Same but eventually
once you get your hyperdrive it's sort
of like all right you go to your map
there are two options free exploration
or the path to the center of the Galaxy
but the more you start playing you start
to you know if you activated that
distress Beacon at the beginning Atlas
will reach out to you and say hey you're
Destiny lies in the Stars so that's yeah
I've seen that that says activate your
hyperdrive so when you do that and you
go up into the the galactic map you know
with all the solar systems it then says
Hey Atlas has something for you over
here
then again that's not really towards the
center of the Galaxy and so then you can
choose to follow that stuff it's
interesting apparently that whole thing
was Rewritten as well uh James swallow
who's when the writer on Deus Ex himself
and Sean Murray basically rewrote the
entire Atlas path as well between these
patches that's pretty I'm glad to know
you know I read that and I forgot about
it but I'm glad to hear that it actually
is a path and not just a Meandering
circling the drain so it's the atlas
path just going straight to the center
as fast as possible was the third I
don't know uh so the third are yeah
that's not it's not yeah he's just not I
thought I may have just missed it no no
you can you can just read it off his
update because he mentions it there I
don't actually kind of actually see it
here on this update it's the same it's
the one we sort of alluded to earlier
it's the uh uh the other names right
yeah it's it's these two Travelers that
are
they have a lot of Higher Learning under
their belt and they're very smart and
experienced and you encounter them once
in a while now it's not I haven't
encountered them yet I only heard about
them but I haven't actually seen them
yet they present you with I think four
options to Aid your quest whatever it
may be and I think it allows you to
Pivot as well so if you want to change
your direction and say maybe I don't
want to do Alice anymore I want to do
this other thing it'll give you an
incentive to make that not like a really
difficult decision okay but I but
somehow you can follow them as well and
that's not totally clear to me at this
point how you do that a lot of other
additions to the game including just
more variety apparently like terrain
generation the atmospheres are planets
the planets themselves the diversity of
the creatures apparently there was no
feeding before animals there was feeding
oh no maybe the animals didn't feed
maybe they didn't have like the ecology
or something there I think what you can
do now is you can feed them a specific
element all right
that just sounds cruel in some cases
give them like a radio
yeah no no I think for I forget how how
it works but essentially I think they
laid out the fact that if you give them
the certain element they'll befriend you
versus just not yeah be hostile
um or they poop something out Boop I
keep hearing that they might poop
something I think those Colombian cats
not to go off topic watch the coffee
they feed the cats yeah sorry and so I
just poured me uh um but one of the
other changes that's really nice is they
let you scan the terrain from your ship
before you would have to land to scan or
use your eyes but because of the draw
distance it's hard to really use you
know visual scanning method oh my God
that's insane you couldn't do that from
the ship before yeah so you would have
to land and then and you couldn't do it
in outer space either you could wow so
you would essentially just yeah that's
not so it's made a lot of things easier
Apparently one of the things I did
notice as well at least from the
trailers and from the version that I'm
playing is that the amount of pop in and
artifacting that happens I mean it's
still there it's still there you know
it's it's there and in there and it
reminds me of like GTA fours where it
was like there all the time but you kind
of got used to it yeah it's nowhere near
severe I think is what it was previously
at least I'm like I noticed it
immediately and I was like yeah this is
this is better and then I just now it
just feels normal yeah there's still
some popping but uh so do you think
interesting that all this is it a worry
to you and you see like all of this
crazy stuff getting rushed into a game
last minute no no is it just a reality
of going gold that like do you get this
many boxes printed you need to yeah it's
the reality of having someone publish
your game right
there's a really interesting uh did you
read that blog post uh Remy yes yeah
yeah really about like what going gold
really means and what it doesn't mean as
much as we thought it would and how like
hello games are still essentially
working the same hours in the last month
well and they're beholden to a dead you
know well not an outdated system
basically where people can publish by
themselves on Steam and control how all
of that rolls out uh console makers have
to you know this unspoken quality seal
of quality and like all this and that
that like Publishers expect games to
meet that and it's there's all sorts of
milestones and weird business stuff
involved we had uh Rob and I did a trip
recently down to another studio and one
of the heads of the studio was saying
like yeah hopefully later this week
we'll we'll pass cert whatever that
means anymore so I was like what is he
talking about this is before like the No
Man's Sky stuff yeah uh you can pick
that up on Rami ismail.com as well that
blog it's really good or am i i s m a i
l uh yeah fascinating read
um uh crazy I guess that like they were
working on this up the up until launch
and it would continue to work on it but
I looked at the credits on the game and
it's nuts because it's basically one
page it's like 20 odd people yeah who
work at hello games then the next page
is like a couple of people when you use
like they're they're all PR managers on
there and a couple of other people like
they're saying thank you to and then
it's like 10 pages of Sony yeah it's
just like QA and like Biz Dev and like
every single like Adam boys is on there
like every person who was even touched a
Sony products name is on it uh yeah it
really shows you this team this game was
made by a tiny like a very for the type
of game it is and especially considering
none of them have really made a game
like this like they're all you know they
made Joe Danger previously they've all
worked on bigger games like Burnett and
stuff like that working in in the sort
of The Wider South England game
development world but uh yeah it's nuts
what's really exciting for me is that
they have gotten to the point to release
this game and what that means is they're
offering what they promised now they get
to deliver other things they didn't
promise because they didn't know if they
could pull it off do you think they're
going to add to it the art the next the
next update that they said is gonna have
it's gonna let you build your own
outposts
what really yes you're going to have
permanent pets like they're going to
keep adding to this game somebody asked
me on Twitter earlier the Nintendo Labs
building outbursts I was like nah
I don't I probably won't want to I hated
it in Fallout but like I'm just I'm just
super stoked that okay the lattice is
there now they can just keep tacking
things onto it and hopefully that they
work and make it great yeah I haven't
even thought about the fact that this is
like Minecraft 1.0 now yeah and then
they get to yeah add to it interesting
stuff
like my hearty I'll keep playing head
off to England yeah we don't need you
anymore get out of here yeah right now
great times by the way to fly away to
Europe for a week and a half yeah oh I
know thanks no man's Sky good job I'm
working on another game stuff right now
another game stuff
not a speaker I'm working on stuff for
another game but I will be playing no
man's Sky when possible are you working
on embargo
and embargo yeah for the makers of
embargo it'll go up Thursday some of it
Tuesday the rest of it I want someone to
make a game called embargo
push the button and release information
wait
[Laughter]
can I guess what sure is it is it is it
embargo X or Deus embargo no oh no it's
not a review okay it's just like is it
no because because eventually you're
gonna have to you shouldn't have said no
then because I'm going to ask you the
next one and then you're going to be
able to go I don't know I want to hear
what the other names would be if your
guess is the way embargo field embargo
fall embargo Falls embargoalization six
and embargo Fields one pirates of the
Embargo being
Motorsport embargo yeah uh Call of Duty
embarging it Warfare we're naming new
games
Call of Duty infinite embargo
that's the winner that's working in the
game Express
uh is it embargo 2 or embargo remastered
Infinity asks
I I honestly don't even know if I can
say what it is no I don't probably not
say anything because I don't know what
was that let's move along let's move
along all right all right all right
we're done thank you so much everyone
for watching today's the lobby thank you
for hosting for the past two weeks yeah
thank you for promising the hosts
have a great time in England yeah enjoy
Gamescom well it's good fun eat the pork
knuckle it's delicious you're probably
just gonna eat it once yeah yeah that'll
be the only meal you probably yeah
you're not going games I'm not going
we're done with Gamescom the Peter Brown
Daniel Dwyer Gamescom experience is dead
I think so it was a good run it was good
fun yeah lots of remember that last
place we had in where they had the weird
German army hats you mean every place
yeah I guess enjoy have fun and you have
fun internet thank you for watching the
show we'll be back next week same bath
time Tuesday 2PM Pacific right here on
gamespot.com stay tuned to the Saito on
YouTube because we have Bunches of No
Man's Sky stuff going up we've Bunch
shows of bunchos Bunches of embargo
stuff going up as well on Thursday and
loads more thank you for watching and
we'll see you next time thank you to
everyone in the back to put the show
together Reggie Merry Christmas
okay